guten morgen je s comfy you so today as
our nook said I'm going to talk about
things but I think I know what you're
talking about but I'm not quite sure
so I'm Jen I'm a front-end developer I
am currently a software out of our
software engineer at Eventbrite as an
oak said and you may know me as the
creator of human wasteland also known as
the poop map particularly those of you
from the Bay Area you may also know me
as the creator of developers developers
which is a project I recently created as
a dedication to mr. Steve Ballmer but
all of that is just a long-winded way of
saying that I write code for a living
before we get started some quick
disclaimers there are going to be a lot
of animated gifts in this talk and there
may be a few errors so if you notice any
of those errors before you start to feel
a little bit like this or a little bit
like this let's talk about it but come
and find me after my talk so let's go as
I said I'm a developer
software engineer programmer or whatever
else you might want to call me so some
days when I look at my computer this is
how I feel and I'm pretty sure many of
you can relate to that feeling and
sometimes when I'm in conversation with
other developers
I feel like this so Phil Carlson once
said there are two only two hard things
in computer science cache and validation
and naming things and we can see that in
the many various complicated terms in
computer science and web development so
here is just a general sampling of some
of the words I've come across in my
career as a programmer and oftentimes I
hear them and I'm like they're a little
bit familiar I think I know what you're
talking about but I'm not really sure
and so in those conversations I often
ask people can you explain that word to
me and in doing so I get a look like
this and when I get that look from other
people it makes me feel like this so
again these words are very complicated
they have very checkered pasts they have
very interesting history they come from
all different places and so today I'm
going to go over a few of those terms so
when you hear them in conversation
perhaps you'll feel a little bit less
like this and you'll feel a little bit
more like this yeah Brent grambo all
right so first up is parameter versus
argument what's the difference is there
one so to find out I of course went to
Google and when I search parameter
argument you'll see many people are
wondering about the difference between
the two because you can see it's the
third query down that's auto-filled
so here I've written a function it's
called shark and I call shark at the
very bottom with the string left
so how many people in the audience think
that the parameter is that first in that
first line slot the side raise your hand
and how many people think it is the
string left in the bottom line of this
code raise your hand and obviously I'm
raising my hand both times so you guys
don't know all right well I'm not gonna
tell you but I'm gonna keep going
so parameter and the online etymology
dictionary and etymology is essentially
the history of words says that parameter
is a measurable factor which helps to
define a particular system and when I
read that I'm like oh okay I think I
know which one is the parameter now but
I keep going and when I search argument
on the online etymology dictionary I
find that there's just information about
people arguing with each other so I'm
like well that doesn't explain to me
what an argument is then so I keep going
and I check out computer programming on
Wikipedia and here I see that the term
parameter sometimes called the formal
parameter is often used to refer to the
variable as found in the function
definition while argument sometimes
called the actual parameter refers to
the actual input passed and because I'm
a developer Mike okay this definition
makes sense to me but I wonder why
didn't we stick with the terms formal
parameter and actual parameter and to
find that out we've got to go down the
rabbit hole so I look up mathematics I
search parameter and argument in
mathematics on Wikipedia and I find that
a function definition can also contain
parameters but unlike variables
parameters are not listed among the
arguments that the function takes now
Mike what does that mean Wikipedia like
please go on so we see here that the
variable X designates the functions
argument but a B and C are the
parameters so I look at this quadratic
function and I see that
X is the argument and a B and C are the
parameters and I was like wait wait a
second so I have a math function up on
top and we see that a is the parameter
then I have a computer science or a
function of JavaScript and I see that
bar is the parameter and like whoa
that's totally messing me up right now
so the way I explain it is that this
Bulldog is a parameter computer science
is the football and so as soon as a
parameter hits computer science its
definition just gets flipped completely
on its end
so the takeaway here for me is actually
that parameters help define a function
and arguments are passed into a function
but that's only in computer science so
here's our answer the parameter is up on
top and shark in the function definition
and then the argument is down at the
bottom that's string last in the
function call and all of that being said
we just use parameter and argument
interchangeably anyways so that was easy
right all right next up is scope so I
don't know about all of you but when
somebody asks me to talk about scope I'm
like I don't want to talk about scope
please don't make me talk about scope
but I'm gonna talk about it today so
first up is lexical scoping and of
course I go back to Google and I see
that lexical scoping parentheses
sometimes known as static scoping is a
convention used with many programming
languages that sets the scope or range
of functionality of a variable so that
it may be only be called or referenced
from within the block of code in which
it is defined so that definition has
three different equivalent definitions
just within it so they say that lexical
scoping is equivalent to static scoping
scope is related to or is equivalent to
range of functionality and called is
equivalent to reference were stop what's
the worst of all is they actually use
the term scope in the definition of
lexical scoping so let's break it down a
little bit scope in the online etymology
dictionary is an aim purpose object
thing aimed at mark or target and am I
can have that doesn't really explain it
in computer science for me so let's keep
going so I search scope on Wikipedia and
I see that a scope is a part of a
program that is
or can be the scope for a set of
bindings a precise definition is tricky
see below
okay thanks a lot Wikipedia I guess I'll
see below so below I see that in
computer programming the scope of a name
binding an association of a name to an
entity such as a variable is the part of
a computer program where the binding is
valid where the name can be used to
refer to the entity and I'm like well
that makes sense to me because I know
what scope is already but somebody who's
new to programming may come and read
this and be like I don't really know
what you're talking about and so when I
read this I'm like it's an okay
definition so I keep going same article
on scope in Wikipedia and then they say
the strict definition of lexical scope
of a name or identifier is unambiguous
and like thanks a lot Wikipedia you're
so condescending it's unambiguous but it
says that it is quote the portion of
source code in which a binding of a name
with an entity applies and I'm like okay
that makes sense to me it's pretty short
and sweet and I keep reading and I see
that it has been virtually unchanged
from its 1960 definition in the
specification of Algol 60 and I don't
know about y'all but when I saw Algol 60
it was like I don't know what that is
so Algol 60 is short for algorithmic
language of 1960 and alwal 60 was the
first language implementing nested
function definitions with lexical scope
and I was like wait so we've had the
definition of lexical scope since 1960
and it's still so hard to explain to
other people but moving on so let's talk
about lexical versus dynamic scope so
lexical scope is the main focus of that
Wikipedia article with dynamic scope
understood by contrast with lexical
scope so I read this and I'm like really
like I have to know what lexical scope
is first before you can even define
dynamic scope for me
all right so let's get a little bit
deeper so lexical on the online
etymology dictionary means pertaining to
words I like huh okay what about dynamic
and dynamic means pertaining to force
producing motion or the opposite of
static and I was like oh that's pretty
interesting because at first definition
of lexical scoping on Google said that
lexical scoping is also static scoping
so I keep going and look up more about
the scope on Wikipedia again and for
most programming languages part of a
program refers to a portion of the
source code or area of texts and is
known as lexical scope like oh okay
that's where pertaining the words comes
from and then in some languages however
part of a program refers to the quote
portion of run time or time period
during execution and that's known as
dynamic scope and then I keep reading
below and I see both of these terms are
somewhat misleading
oh my goal and I keep reading they
misuse technical terms as discussed in
the definition then I go so what I just
read is wrong and then I keep reading
that says but the distinction itself is
accurate and precise and these are the
standard respective terms like oh so
what I just read was right okay so I
keep reading again of course and we see
that in practice with lexical scope a
variables definition is resolved by
searching its containing block or
function then if that fails searching
the outer containing block and so on
whereas with dynamic scope the calling
function is searched then the function
which called that calling function and
so on oh my go
that's that's pretty clear I think that
makes sense to me so all that being said
this is a JavaScript conference so who
cares about dynamic scope so the way I
like to think about lexical scope is
the box is a function the orange cat is
a variable in that function the orange
cat can see the white cat but the white
cat can't see the orange cat
okay next up is recursion so recursion
on the online etymology dictionary
refers to a running backwards or to
return or to run back yeah like that
kind of makes sense but not quite
related to computer science so I look up
recursion on Wikipedia and I read that
the most common application of recursion
is in mathematics and computer science
in which it refers to a method of
defining functions in which the function
being defined is applied within its own
definition and I was like wait I thought
this was a definition why is why are we
defining so many different definitions
within its definition so I keep reading
and I see that specifically this defines
an infinite number of instances or
function values using a finite
expression that for some instances may
refer to other instances and in such a
way that no loop or infinite chain of
references can occur
let's keep going
so I keep reading down this article and
I see that in mathematics and computer
science a class of objects or methods
exhibit recursive behavior when they can
be defined by two properties number one
a simple base case or cases a
terminating scenario that does not use
recursion to produce an answer and
number two a set of rules that reduce
all other cases toward that base case
and again that kind of makes sense to me
because I am a developer but for
somebody's who's new they probably are
gonna give me a look like this when they
read that so at its base I like to
describe recursion as a function that
calls itself that's what I would like to
see on Wikipedia instead so oftentimes
people will explain recursion to other
people by saying this and then they
decide to get a little bit more
complicated and talk about the Fibonacci
sequence and I'm like oh god I took math
like over a decade ago I don't know
about y'all but I see this and I'm like
I don't even remember what the Fibonacci
sequence is so when somebody starts to
explain recursion to me by talking about
the Fibonacci sequence I'm like whatever
one time though a friend explains to me
recursion by talking about factorials
and I think everybody really likes
factorials because they have this cute
little exclamation point and if you
remember them from more like elementary
or middle school mathematics and like oh
that makes a lot more sense and I really
like that definition of recursion so
when somebody talks about that I feel a
lot more like this like yeah that's a
good example all right next is
concatenation so concatenation on the
online etymology dictionary refers to a
linking together to link together a
chain and I was like whoa we actually
use that word correctly in computer
science go us but really the true reason
I want to bring up this word is because
it's got cat in it
and this is my cat everything's better
con cat and here's a recursive cat
it's stuck in that infinite loop of a
function I don't know okay
anyways next up is instantiate so
instantiate from the online etymology
dictionary it comes from instant and it
was created in 1946 and oh my god that's
pretty recent actually and then i go to
google and i'm like what does
instantiate mean and it means to
represent as or by an instance and their
example is a study of two groups who
seem to instantiate productive aspects
of this this what as if this wasn't
confusing enough in JavaScript
so in Wikipedia when I searched
instantiation I actually come across
philosophy and it says that in predicate
logic Universal instantiation also known
as UI also called Universal
specification or Universal elimination
and sometimes confused with dictum dyani
is a valid role of inference from a
truth about each member of a class of
individuals to the truth about a
particular individual of that class
sounds like ok that kind of makes sense
but basically all cats are mammals fry
as a cat and therefore fry as a mammal
so that's Universal Universal
instantiation and philosophy so here I
have a class that I've created called
mammal and a class that I've called cats
and I set the cat's prototype to mammal
and instantiate a new cat here called
fried cat
so basically fry is the cat all cats are
mammals and so therefore fried cat is
also a mammal I was like cool another
good thing that we have correct in
computer science instantiation but
weirdly
the online etymology dictionary
instantiation actually redirects to
instantiate and on wikipedia instantiate
redirects to instantiation so we only
have either the noun form or the verb
form you can't have both apparently
anyways moving on to acronyms so here
are some acronyms I always get confused
CRM CMS and CDN and just to go over them
again because they're very confusing CRM
is a customer relationship manager kind
of like salesforce a CMS is a content
management system it's kind of like
wordpress and a CDN is a content
delivery network kind of like Amazon
OUTFRONT next is SAS versus SAS when
you're talking about SAS please clarify
to me which one you are talking about
are you talking about software as a
service like Salesforce or are you
talking about syntactically awesome
style sheets which is the CSS extension
language I don't know but if you don't
tell me that I'm gonna get sassy about
it next is Dom so there are many kinds
of Dom this is graz or Dom which is a
chapel in Austria this is dumb the indie
rock band and this is V DOM which is a
mountain located in the Alps
and again we see that word SAS
so there are many kinds of Dom but the
Dom that we're interested in is the
document object model wikipedia says
that the Dom is a cross-platform and
language independent convention for
representing and interacting with
objects in HTML XHTML and XML documents
and I go it kind of makes sense to me
let's keep looking for another
definition so I search Mozilla
developers Network and I see that the
Dom is a programming interface for HTML
XML and SVG documents it provides a
structure representation of the document
a tree and it defines a way that the
structure can be accessed from programs
so that they can change the document
structure style and content then I go ok
that makes a little bit more sense to me
thanks mdn best of all they actually
have an illustration of the tree and I'm
like oh that's the Dom that's what it
looks like cool alright next is GUI and
CLI so I like to call CLI Klee because
if we call it GUI why can't we call it
clean so when I hear GUI this is what I
think of I think of gooey butter cake
and then I just can't work anymore I
also think about gooey ducts I'm not
sure if you all know what that is but
it's basically a weird by valve that
lives in the ocean it's also edible kind
of tasty little things but strangely
this is actually how you spell gooey
duck kind of counterintuitive and then
when I read CLI I read it as klieg N and
that makes me think about Paul Klee the
painter but most of us I think really
know that gooey our graphical user
interfaces and they were first
introduced in reaction to the perceived
steep learning curve of command-line
interfaces or Cleese as I like to call
them which require commands to be typed
on the keyboard and lastly I have Ajax I
love the word Ajax but it's really
outdated
because who even uses XML I also found
it recently that jate but jQuery AJAX
method has an option to set a sink to
false so that means that you can
actually be running s judge all right
in conclusion so oftentimes when we hear
these terms we're like I have no idea
what you're talking about and as soon as
you understand it you just get it and
because you just get it it makes it
really hard to explain those terms to
somebody else you kind of have to wait
for them and you kind of have to nudge
them until that light bulb just hits so
I know it's really difficult to explain
other people but I implore you when
somebody asks you to explain a term try
not to be like this or like this we're
trying to pass the buck to make somebody
else explain it because you don't feel
like it
and try to please be a little bit more
like this because it's really difficult
it's so hard to understand and let's
watch this video so we see here number
12 has just fallen on the ice and she's
like I don't understand what GUI is
everyone around me is talking about GUI
they're all talking about GUI and I
don't know what it means another number
12 is like let me help you I'm gonna
explain GUI to you GUI it's just the
graphical user interface and other
number 12 is like I understand thank you
so when we're all a little bit more like
these number 12 then we can party
together in the computer science jargon
land thanks so much